this book's either gonna ruin my life or
change my life so i've gotta
i've gotta see what this is all about
[Music]
i discovered this book story of the eye
through cliff sergeants
channel uh better than food which is a
wonderful channel where i find a lot of
great uh often unusual book
recommendations that i haven't heard of
before
story of the eye by georges bataille
bataai so this is a book basically about
eroticism
and death what i want to do today is
just approach it as a reading experience
regardless of whatever philosophical
ideas is trying to convey which i don't
think they're
i i don't think you have to read it
necessarily to gather
a certain philosophy you can read it as
a visceral
experience because that's how i was able
to really appreciate this
very enjoyable and also really gross
i think that's the point and everything
they say about this book that it's
very graphic it's grotesque it's true
i'll just say this is not the setting to
go into details
uh you could read a plot synopsis if you
want but hey the book is so short you
could just read it yourself if you're
curious my initial reaction to the story
is like it's just
absolutely absurd these characters are
ridiculous
they're just sex criminal maniacs i mean
it's just a story
about these these absolute maniacs who
are
so freaking horny that they just can't
help themselves to
do the most depraved [ __ ] in the world
it just becomes more dangerous and
revolting
and disturbing and violent as the story
goes on
i actually think it's it was kind of
funny and i think there's
a sense of humor like running through
this book the way
disturbing stuff is glossed over or the
way narrative moments are just kind of
like well this happened and then
now we're here well they went and stole
a boat and
robbed a bank and then they were in this
place and they had a benefactor and
everything was fine
it's like what i
most enjoyed about this book was that it
was always surprising challenged my
expectations
i will never look at eggs the same way
again
the passions of these characters even
though it is extremely
violent gruesome it's kind of amazing
at first and you when you read about
these characters and the the passion
that they have
for erotic feeling so much could be
talked about and written about within
these few pages
yet what is most valuable to me as a
reader is just the
the sheer narrative experience the
absolute
freedom and abandon i yeah i don't
regret reading it
i did have like a stomachache after
reading it you start the book and you're
like oh yeah these people they like
having sex cool
awesome you have fun and then at the end
of the book you're just like
please stop basically i do recommend
this book
with the warning that it's a bit
uh much
it's just nothing like i've ever read
end of end of video